hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game it's from round two
of the uh rapid and blitz tournament we
are now covering it
versus atm and it features a very
interesting move that you will be uh you
will be given an
opportunity to find so without further
ado let's check it out it's a very short
game but
a very enjoyable one so uh
jan opens with e4 we have c5 sorry about
that
going for the sicilian defense we have
knight to f3 d6
and now bishop to b5 check going for the
canal attack we have bishop to d7
and now bishop captures on d7 we have
queen captures and castle so nothing
out of the ordinary here we have knight
to f6 and rook to e1
we have knight to c6 adding more uh
pressure to the center here
and c3 now preparing to further expand
in the center with the d4 we have e6 and
now d4 and this has all been
been played before uh nothing nothing
new here so captures captures and then
now
d5 black manages to get this d5 moving
and now if white allows capture so if
white captures on d5 then white can
can't really claim any uh advantage of
the white pieces
uh so he has to play e5 he has to
advance the pawn
and now knight to the e4 so for the
moment he gives black this very strong
e4 square
but he uh kicks it away with knight b to
d2 so now this knight can't really
remain
here uh so back trades here on d2 we
have knight captures bishop captures and
now
there are over 400 games in the database
with this exact same position just
bishop to e7 castles and
uh the game continues but here we have
a5 by
atn and it is now as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
what etienne's idea is here
uh nipple continues with rook to c1 he
develops a
rook into the game and now a4
maybe with some ideas of a3 trying to
uh well either force something like b3
or if captures then the rook will
capture and then you will
have a very very active rook on the a
file so here a3
uh nipple doesn't allow this and now
bishop to e7
uh just continuing development uh if
you're considering knights the a5 seems
like a very nice idea then bring the
knight over to b3 or c4 black will
wipe very happy give up the dark square
bishop for this knight because it isn't
really doing anything
white spawns are in dark squares and
this bishop
well it it's better grabbing the knight
and now for example captures queen d2 we
attacked the rook
and after the rook moves now we're gonna
double up rooks on the c file while the
black king is still in the center of the
board so maybe something to consider
so instead of this like i said bishop to
e7 and now
h4 so what do you play here we have
castles and
now rook the c3 already uh throwing a
rook lift into the game
now the knight can move you can bring
maybe the rook to g3
who knows what what might happen uh we
have rook f the c8 by back row and
now rook to d3 first we have to defend
the d4 pawn and now our knight can move
so here
we have b5 uh just further expanding on
the queen side but nepo says that this
game is not about the queen side and he
throws in a nice knight to g5 and knight
to g5 is just a
just a barbarian move uh there's no
there's no reason for it it's just
there to to annoy black and you know
good things might happen
so here uh bakr goes h6 he wants to kick
the knight away but also checking if
nepo is maybe interested in some crazy
knight captures on f7 action
and uh we know that nipple is always
interested but here it it
doesn't work and it's very easy to see
why because after knight captures king
captures
and now yes we can bring a queen into
the game with czech king j8 and bishop
captures an h6
now black will not capture and allow
rook to g3 but black will just play
bishop to f8 and now there is sufficient
the defense here
uh you will be able you have plenty of
time to bring your other pieces into the
game
and black will just have a well a
winning game so instead
nepo has to go back we have knights to
h3 and now
king the h8 now the rooks can also join
uh join the the the defense via moves
like rook to g8
so here we have queen to g4 by nipple
now bringing the queen into the
attack of course that's why the king did
the sidestep now you can bring the rooks
into the game
uh but now he doesn't and uh the the
best thing to do actually here would be
bishop to f8 and just defending the g7
pawn
and the black is defending sufficiently
you can maybe bring the knight to the e7
to f5
so it should work however here backroad
played
f5 and this is a bit too too premature
here we have queen to
g6 now with the idea of just bishop
captures an h6 so you have to defend
against this so here we have bishop
captures on h4
and now has white suc has black
successfully defended against this idea
uh by capturing an h4 uh it's hard to
tell but feel free to pause the video
here and
try to find it the only winning move for
nipple here in this amazing position
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not
grabbing this pawn uh because it doesn't
work i'm going to show you why it
doesn't work because after captures
captures and captures with check we can
block with the queen and now you don't
get to pick up the bishop here so that's
a problem even after queen captures an
e60 yes you've
made some damage there's a past e pawn
but 97 everything is nicely defended
this defense this this defends this
we're gonna play rook the c6 attack the
queen this rook is coming to g8
so black has everything covered and uh
well
if all is played well black should not
have a problem defending this
however if after bishop captures an h4
you found queen to
h5 then congratulations because this is
the only move that wins
it's a very sneaky idea it's the one
that nipple found and now
white is definitely winning so
congratulations to all of you
uh but now uh there there's no good
square for the bishop queen captures
bishop is coming and you don't have a
good square for example
uh you can't place the bishop here
because the h pawn is pinned you you
will not be able to capture back this is
covered by the pawn
if you play bishop to e7 then the queen
no longer covers the seventh rank then
we just capture and
we're just winning even if bishop to f8
now
we're still uh uh able to do a nice
discovery here so just bishop captures
with a double check king captures and
now
rook to g3 will be checkmate because the
queen covers here
palm covers here and the rook and queen
cover the g h
file so after queen to h5 you don't
really have a good move here you have to
do something
but there is nothing to be done if queen
e7 trying to guard a bishop like this
just g3 and the bishop is lost so
there's no saving this bishop so in the
game uh bakra
decided after queen to h5 let's go back
all the way bishop to the eight now at
least my queen still covers this but
it's still not enough nipple captures on
h6 we have g
captures instead of capturing you could
also just move the king but it's still
not enough just bishop captures and rook
to g3 is coming there there's no
there's no defense against this it's
simply too much to handle
so instead after bishop captures an h6 g
captures on h6 which played that this is
the
only way to do it but now nipple just
played rook to g3 again the absolute
monster move
uh and it was in this position animal 24
that etienne bakr resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
uh the problem is uh this is being
threatened
and there is no way to defend it if you
try something like king to h7 and we're
just gonna play queen g6 checking it
and this will be checkmate now and on
the other hand if you try defending with
the queen let's say you try something
like this
then the e8 square is available so queen
e8 check and now again you have to play
this queen captures and g8 will be
checkmate so after work to g3
there really is no way to play this and
like i said it was in this position that
etienne bakr
resigned the game so really really
impressive stuff by nippo and you can
see how good things happen even
when you're playing your own game so you
always have to do this if your opponent
allows it
at such a position uh you know just uh
just throw it in knight to g5 like it
might not be doing anything
but it uh well it created a weakness in
the position
uh black doesn't have to play h6 but
then you just allow this knight to
remain here
of course but black did play h6 you
weakened black's position
and then you used this weakness later on
to hone in on it and create
further more weaknesses and then well
you've seen what happened in the game
so try try and use this in your own
games so once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it yeah keep using hashtag
suggestion to suggest
any game that is played anywhere in the
world if it's a nice one we're going to
cover it
i would like to thank john austin ben
blackburn uh
abhinav and uh for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and do join us on the tournament
tomorrow the links are in the
description below
see you soon